Special Counsel Robert Muller reportedly
has told president Trump's lawyers he is
not a criminal target in the Russia
probe right now that's according to the
Washington Post but Muller is still
investigating the president for
potential obstruction of justice Paula
Reid is at the White House Paula
let me ask you this if the president was
a criminal car target is that something
Muller would tell the president and is
that even possible for a president to be
a target of a criminal investigation a
lot of questions there first of all
sources close to the investigation tell
me up till now there is no evidence that
the president has actually committed a
crime so he's not considered an official
target that's a bit of tricky legal
nuance because your behavior can be
under scrutiny while you're not
officially considered a criminal target
investigators continue to examine the
president's actions during the firing of
James Comey as well as other
interactions he had with top justice
officials and there are ongoing
negotiations about whether the president
will be interviewed as part of that
probe and just yesterday the first
person was sentenced in the special
counsels investigation
Alex vanderzwaan a dutch attorney who
worked closely with former Trump
campaign chairman Paul Manafort he
received a sentence of 30 days you look
at court documents and they suggest that
he has provided evidence to special
counsel about contacts between the Trump
campaign and Russia at the end of all of
this we may get more answers because
Special Counsel Robert Muller is
expected to compile a full report with
all of his investigations findings what
is not clear is whether that report will
ever be made public Gael all right Paula
thank you